i felt to be a good partner
there was no accountability
will smith
was defending her honor
that was why the reason he walked on
stage and slapped
because he felt like his will his wife
had been offended
viveka a fox is calling out jada pinkett
smith's remarks about the slap seen
around the world
wow
on the wendy williams show vivica who
was guest hosting got visibly upset over
jada's latest episode of red table talk
where she finally broke her silence on
her husband will smith slapping chris
rock at the oscars my deepest hope is
that these two intelligent capable men
have an opportunity to heal talk this
out
and reconcile the state of the world
today
we need them both and we all actually
need one another more than ever
vivica says it was emotional for her to
watch that especially being so close to
both will and jada this is going to be
difficult for me
these are my
peers done a movie with
both of them set it off with jada
and independence day with will smith
which absolutely changed my life
when i saw this video last night
it made me cry i'll be very honest with
you guys
she then fought back tears talking about
how the night was supposed to be a
celebration i really felt to be a
partner
to will smith
whose career
basically took a crumble that night
we were all rooting for will smith that
night
oscar night we wanted him to win
will smith that night as far as i was
concerned was going to be crowned this
generation's sidney poitier which is a
huge honor
since working together on independence
day vivica has remained a big will fan
but in 2015 she told et it's his
humility she admires most you know what
i love about will is that throughout the
transition from going from television to
major movie star he's always stayed
humble
down the earth so welcoming he always
includes me in all of his premieres and
i just love him to pieces i do
so when it comes to the oscar slap
viveka explained why she feels jada had
a role in the incident too you'll recall
will slapped chris after he made a joke
about jada's shaved head a joke that
didn't go over well with the actress
who's made it publicly known she
struggles with alopecia a hair loss
disorder will smith
was defending her honor
that was why the reason he walked on
stage and slapped
because he felt like his will his wife
had been offended
i have love for the smiths i know their
children i've watched them grow up i
just wish that we could have had a
little bit more accountability
and it for it to not seem
so
self-righteous on jada's part as for
jada she's ready to move forward in a
positive way the more that we can bring
these difficult subjects to light and
talk about it the more we can purify
these subjects she explained on red
table talk she's now focused on shedding
light on the autoimmune disease i felt
like it was so important to just
allow
the alopecia community our brothers and
sisters to tell their story i think that
people don't understand what alopecia is
and they don't understand the effects of
it
[Music]